YUFEI ZHAO: For the
past couple lectures,
we've been talking
about Roth's theorem.
And we showed-- so we saw
a proof of Roth's theorem
using Fourier analytic methods.
And we saw basically
the same proof
but in two different settings.
So two lectures ago,
we saw a proof in F3
to the M And basically
the same strategy,
but with a bit
more work, we were
able to show Roth's theorem
worth roughly comparable bounds
over the integers.
Today, I want to show you a
very different kind of proof
of Roth's theorem in the
finite fieldfini setting.
So first let me remind
you, the bound that we
saw last time for
Roth's in F3 to the M
gave an upper bound
on the maximum number
of elements in the 3-AP-free
set that were of the form
3 to the n over n.
And so this proof
wasn't too bad.
So we did it in one lecture.
And then with a lot more
work-- and people tried very,
very hard to improve this--
and there was a paper that got
it to just a little bit more.
And this was a lot of work.
And this was something
that people thought
was very exciting at the time.
And then just a few years ago,
there was a major breakthrough,
a very surprising
breakthrough, where--
you know, at this point,
it wasn't even clear
whether 3 should be the
right base for this exponent.
That was a big open problem.
And then there was
a big breakthrough
where the following
bound was proved,
that it was exponentially
less than the previous bound.
So this is one that I want to
talk about in the first part
of today's lecture.
So this development came first--
the history is a
bit interesting.
So Croot, Lev, and
Pach uploaded a paper
to the archive May 5 of
2016, where they showed not
exactly this theorem but in
a slightly different setting
in this group, so in Z
mod 4 instead of Z mod 3.
And this was already
quite exciting,
getting exponential
improvement in this setting.
But it wasn't
exactly obvious how
to use their method to get F3.
But that was done
about a week later.
So Ellenberg and Gijswijt,
they managed to improve the--
use this technique to modify
the Croot-Lev-Pach technique
to the F2 to the n setting,
which is the one that we've
been interested in.
So there's a small
difference between these two,
namely this group has
elements of order 2, which
makes things a bit easier
to do it here with.
So this is the
Croot-Lev-Pach method,
as it's often called
in literature.
And we'll see that--
it's a very ingenious use
of the so-called
linear algebraic method
in combinatorics, in this
case the polynomial method.
And it works specifically in
the finite field vector space.
So what we're talking about
in this part of the lecture
does not translate whatsoever.
At least, nobody knows how
to translate this technique
to the integer setting.
So how does it work?
The presentation
I'm going to give
follows not the original paper,
which is quite nice to read,
by the way.
It's only about four pages long.
It's pleasant to read.
But there's is a slightly
even nicer formulation
on Terry Tao's blog.
And that's the one
that I'm presenting.
So the idea is that if
you have a subset of F3
to the n that is
3-AP-free, such a set also
has a name capset, which
is also used in literature
in this specific
setting where you have
no three points on the line.
In this case, then we have
the following identity.
So here delta is
the Dirac delta.
Let me write that
down in a second.
So the delta of a
is the Dirac delta.
It's either 1 if x equals to a,
and 0 if x does not equal to a.
So this is simply
rewriting the fact
that x, y, z form
a 3-AP if and only
if their sum is equal to 0.
And because you're
3-AP-free, the only 3-AP's
are the trivial ones recorded
on the right-hand side.
So this is simply a
recording of the statement
that A is 3-AP-free.
And the idea now is that you
have this expression up there,
and I want to show that
if A is very, very large,
then I could get a
contradiction by considering
some notion of rank.
So we will show that
the left-hand side
is, in some sense, low rank.
Well, I haven't told
you what rank means yet.
But the left-hand side
is somewhat low rank,
and the right-hand side
is a high-rank object.
So what does rank mean.
So recall from linear algebra--
so the classical notion
of rank corresponds
to two variable functions.
So you should think of F as a
matrix over an arbitrary field
F. So such a function or
a corresponding matrix
is called rank 1
if it is nonzero
and it can be written
in the following form--
F of x, y is f of x g
of y for some functions
that are one variable each.
So, in matrix language,
this is a column vector
times a row vector.
So that's the meaning of rank 1.
And to say that something is of
high rank of a specific rank--
rather, the rank of F is
defined to be the minimum number
of rank 1 functions
needed to write F
as a sum or a
linear combination.
So this is rank 1.
And if you add up
r rank 1 functions,
then get something
that's, at most, rank r.
So that's the basic definition
of rank from linear algebra.
For three-variable
functions, you
can come up with
other notions of rank.
So what about
three-variable functions?
So how do we define a
rank of such a function?
So you might have seen such
objects as generalizations
of matrices called tensors.
And tensors have, already,
a natural notion of rank,
and this is called tensor rank.
Just like how, here, F is--
we say rank 1 if it's
decomposable like that,
we say F has tensor rank 1 if
this three-variable function is
decomposable as a product
of one-variable functions.
The tensor rank,
it turns out, this
is an important notion, which
is actually quite mysterious.
There's a lot of
important problems
that boil down to us not really
understanding what tensor rank,
how it behaves.
And it turns out, this
is not the right notion
to use for our problem.
So we're going to use a
different notion of rank.
Here, rank 1 is decomposing
this three-variable function
into a product of three
one-variable functions.
But, instead, I can
define a different notion.
We say that F has slice rank 1--
so this is a definition
that's introduced
in the context of this
problem, although it's also
quite a natural definition--
if it has one of
the following forms.
So I can write it as a product
of a one-variable function
and a two-variable function.
So one variable and the
remaining two variables.
But this definition should also
be symmetric in the variables,
so the other combinations
are OK as well.
So this is the definition
of a rank one function,
a slice rank 1.
And, also, if nonzero.
If it's nonzero and can be
written in one of these forms.
And, just like
earlier, we define
the slice rank of F to be
the minimum number of slice
rank 1 functions.
Same as before, that you
need to write F as a sum.
So I can decompose this F into
a sum of slice rank 1 functions.
What's the most
efficient way to do so?
So that's the definition
of slice rank.
And, you see, you can come
up with this definition
for any number of
variables, where slice rank
1 means decompose into
two functions, where
one function takes one variable,
and the other function takes
all the remaining variables.
And, therefore, two
variables, slice rank and rank
correspond to the same notion.
Any questions so far?
All right.
So let's look at the
function on the right.
So think of it as
a matrix, a tensor.
So what is it?
Well, it's kind of
like a diagonal matrix.
So that's what it is.
It's a diagonal matrix.
So what is the rank of a
diagonal matrix, in this case
a diagonal function?
Well, you know
from linear algebra
that if you have a matrix, then
the rank of a diagonal matrix
is the number of
nonzero entries.
So something similar
is true for slice rank,
although it's less obvious.
It will require a proof.
So if I have this
three-variable function
defined by the
following formula.
So, in other words, it's
a diagonal function where
the entries on the
diagonals are the Ca's.
So what is the rank
of this function?
So the slice rank of
F. In the matrix case,
it will be the number
of nonzero entries,
and it's exactly the same here.
So number of nonzero
diagonal entries.
That turns out to
be the slice rank.
Let's see a proof.
So we go back to the
definition of slice rank.
And we see that one of
the directions is easy.
So this less than or equal to,
greater than or equal to-- so
which one is easy?
So, you see, the right-hand
side is a sum of r--
of a-- well, this
many rank 1 functions.
So this direction is--
so this direction is clear,
just looking at the definition.
I can write F explicitly
as that many rank 1,
slice rank 1 functions.
So the tricky part is
greater than or equal to.
And for the greater
than or equal to,
let's assume that all the
diagonal entries are nonzero.
So why can we do this?
If it's not nonzero,
I claim that we
can remove this element
from A. If the Ca is not 0,
then I remove a from the set.
And doing so cannot
increase the rank.
A priori, the rank might go
down if you get rid of an entry.
Because if you add an entry,
even though the function
doesn't change on the original
set, if you increase your set,
maybe you have more space,
maybe you have more flexibility
to work with.
But, certainly, if you remove an
element, the rank cannot go up.
Now, so suppose
the slice rank of F
is strictly less
than the size of A.
So all these Ca's are nonzero.
So suppose, for
contradiction, that there
is some different way
to write function F that
uses fewer terms.
So what would such
a sum look like?
So I would be able to write this
function F in a different way.
Like that.
And then, now, I look at these--
the other types of functions
using different combination
of the variables.
So suppose there
were a different way
to write this function
F that uses fewer terms.
So I assume it uses exactly
the size of A minus 1 terms,
and always putting zero
functions if you like.
So now I claim that
there exists a function
h on the set A whose support--
so the support is
the number of entries
that give nonzero values.
The support of F is
bigger than m, such
that the following sum is 0.
So I claim that we can
find a function F--
h such that I think of it as
in the kernel of some of these
f's.
So this is a linear
algebraic statement.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What is
h sub [INAUDIBLE]??
YUFEI ZHAO: Ah, sorry.
It's just h.
Thank you.
It's a single function h
such that this equation
is true for all x.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
h of x minus the sum
of all [INAUDIBLE].
YUFEI ZHAO: You are right.
So what do I want to say here?
So we want to find a function
h such that the support of h
is at least m.
So what do we want to say?
I want to say that--
yes, so you're right.
This is not what I want to say.
And, instead, it's something--
mm-hmm.
Yes, good.
So, let's see.
So here we have some
number of functions.
Here, we have some
And for each a, I have--
or for each-- let's see.
Umm, hmm.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
YUFEI ZHAO: I'm sorry?
YUFEI ZHAO: No.
So I do want to show--
no, there's no induction,
because I'm in three variables,
and I want to get rid
of-- so the point is--
so let's see where
we're going eventually,
and then we'll figure out
what happened up there.
So we want to consider--
so I would like to eventually
consider the following sum.
So I want to consider this
sum, which comes from--
so you look at--
wait, no.
That's not the sum
I want to consider.
So let's look at this F of
x, y, z, so F being that sum.
No.
So take that F up there.
And let me consider,
basically, taking
the inner product of
this function viewed
as a function in z.
So consider this inner product.
And if I-- ah.
I think-- so what I
want to say is not this.
So what I want to say is, if I
look at an inner product of h
with the--
so take one of these f's--
take one of these f's
and look at the bilinear
form relating each in f.
So I want to show
that this sum vanishes
for all i between m plus 1
and the size of A minus 1.
So this row, I want it
to vanish when being
taken bilinear form with h.
So that makes sense now.
OK, good.
So the fact that such a
nonzero h exists simply
is a matter of
counting parameters.
It's a linear
algebraic statement.
You have some
number of freedoms.
You have some number
of constraints.
So the set of such h satisfy
all of these constraints.
So there are this
many constraints.
Well, each one of
them could carry down
to one dimension less,
but the set of such h
is a linear subspace of
dimension bigger than m,
because I have A dimensions, and
I have these many constraints.
So the set of such h is-- there
are a lot of possibilities.
And, furthermore, it
is also true that--
and this is a linear
algebraic statement--
that every subspace of
dimension m plus one
has a vector whose support
has size at least m plus 1.
I'll leave this as a
linear algebraic exercise.
It's not entirely
obvious, but it is true.
When you put these
two things together,
you find that there
is some vector--
so I think of the
corners of the vectors
as indexed by the set A--
there is some vector whose
support is large enough.
So we prove the claim.
Let's go back to this lemma
about this diagonal function
having high rank.
Take h from the claim.
So let's take h from the claim.
Then let's consider
this sum over here.
On one hand, what this sum is--
you can do the sum on
the right-hand side.
We see that it's like
multiplying a diagonal matrix
by a vector.
So what you get, following the
formula on the right-hand side,
is the following.
Let me rewrite this part.
Sum over a of C sub a h of
a delta sub a of x delta sub
a of y.
Just looking at the formula
from the right hand side.
On the other hand, if you
had a decomposition up there,
doing this sum and
noting the claim,
we see that the
third row is gone.
So what you would have is
a sum over these z's of--
so let me write that like this.
So you would have a sum that is
of the form f1 of x and g tilde
1 of y, where g
tilde is basically
the inner product of g1
as a function of z with h.
So fl of x gl of y.
And then, also,
functions like that.
So there exists some
functions g, which
come from g tilde,
which come from the g's
up there, such
that this is true.
But now we're in the world
of two-variable functions.
So left and right-hand side
are two-variable functions.
And for two-variable
functions, you
understand what is the rank
of a diagonal function.
So the left-hand side has
more than m diagonal entries,
because h has support.
So the number of
diagonal entries
is just the support of h.
Whereas the right-hand
side has rank--
so now a linear
algebraic matrix rank--
at most, m.
And that's a contradiction.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So you can
show a similar statement
where [INAUDIBLE].
YUFEI ZHAO: Great.
So we can show a
similar statement
for arbitrary
number of variables
by generalizing this
proof and using induction
on the number of variables.
But we only need three
variables for now.
Any questions?
Just to recap, what we
proved is the generalization
of the statement that
a diagonal matrix has
rank equal to the number of
nonzero diagonal entries.
But the same fact is true for
these three-variable functions
with respect to slice rank.
So this is intuitively
obvious, but the execution
is slightly tricky.
All right.
So now we have the
statement here.
Let's proceed to analyze this
function which comes from--
so this relationship here coming
from set A that is 3-AP-free.
So suppose now I'm in--
so let me-- so everything so
far was generally with any A.
But now let me think
about, specifically,
functions on the finite field
vector space, F3 to the n.
So it's a function
taking value F3.
And this function is defined
to be the left-hand side
of that equation over there.
So the claim is that--
so the left-hand side claim
that this function has low rank.
So we claim that a slice rank of
this function is, at most, 3M,
where M is the sum
of, essentially,
this multinomial coefficient.
So we'll analyze this
number in a second,
but this number is
supposed to be small.
So we want to show that this
function here has small rank.
So let's rewrite this
function in a form
explicitly as a sum of
products by expanding
this function after writing it
in a slightly different form.
So in F3, in a three-variable--
in characteristic-- so in
F3, you have this equation.
You can check that it's true
for x equal to 0, 1, or 2.
So picked that, and
plug it in over here.
So we find-- so now x,
y, z are in F3 to the n.
So we find that, applying
this guy here coordinate-wise,
you have this product.
Great.
Now let's pretend we're
expanding everything.
This is a polynomial in 3n
variables, 3n variables.
It's degrees is 2n.
So if we expand, we get
a bunch of monomials.
And the monomials will
have the following form.
So the x's, which--
whose exponents I call i,
the y's, whose
exponents I call j,
and the z's, whose
exponents I call k, where--
so I get a sum of
monomials like that,
where all of these i, j's,
and k's are either 0, 1, or 2.
So I get this big
sum of monomials,
and I want to show that
it's possible to write
this sum as a small number of
functions that can be written
as a product, where
one of the factors only
involves one of x, y, z.
So what we can do
is to group them.
So group these
monomials by the--
so, for example, I'm going
to group these monomials
by using the
following observation.
So by pigeonhole, at least
one of the exponents of x,
or the exponents of y, or the
exponents of z, at least one
of these guys is,
at most, 2n over 3.
So I group these
monomials by the--
one of x, y, z that has
the smallest exponent.
So the contributions to
the rank or the slice
rank from monomials with the
degree of x being, at most,
2n over 3, well, I can
write such contributions
in the form like that, where
this f of x is a monomial,
and the g is a sum of
whatever that could come up.
This is a sum, but
this is a monomial.
So the number of such terms--
so the number of such
terms is the number
of monomials corresponding
to choices of i's, the sum
to 2n over 3, and individual
i's coming from 0, 1, or 2.
And that number is precisely M.
So M counts the number
of choices of 0, 1, 2's.
There are n of them.
And the sums of the i's
is, at most, 2n over 3.
So these are
contributions coming
from monomials where the degree
of x is, at most, 2n over 3.
And, similarly, with
degree of y being
2n over 3, and also degree of
z being, at most, 2n over 3.
So. all the monomials
can be grouped
in one of these three groups,
and I count the contribution
to the slice rank.
AUDIENCE: Do we have a good idea
as to how sharp this bound is?
YUFEI ZHAO: So the
question is, do we
have a good idea as to
how sharp this bound is?
That's a really good question.
I don't know.
Yes.
Great.
So that finishes the
proof of this lemma.
So now we have this lemma.
I can compare-- so we
have these two lemmas.
One of them tells me the rank
of the right-hand side, which
is A. Let's compare
ranks, the slice rank.
So the left-hand side, we know
it is, at most, this quantity.
And the right-hand
side is equal to A.
So we automatically
find this bound.
So now we want to know
how big this number M is.
So there's actually-- this
is a fairly standard problem
to solve to estimate the
growth of this function M. So
let me show you how to do
it, and this is basically
the universal method.
Notice that I can--
if I look at this
number here, where if--
so now x is some real
number between 0 and 1.
Then I claim the
following is true.
And this is because if you
expand the right-hand side
and count your monomials--
so you can just keep track
of which monomials occur,
and there are M of them,
where you can lower
bound by this quantity here.
So this is kind of related to
things in probability theory
on large deviations, to
the Cramér's theorem.
But that's what you can do.
So this is true for every
value of x, so you pick one
that gives you the best bound.
So M is, at most, the inf
of this quantity here.
And to show you
any bound, I just
have to plug in some value.
So if I plug in, for
example, x being 0.6,
I already get a bound which
is the one that I claimed.
And it turns out this
step here is not lossy.
As in, basically, up to 1 plus
little o1 in the exponent,
this is the correct bound.
And that follows from general
results in large deviation
theory.
And that finishes the proof.
Alternatively, you
can also estimate
M using Sterling's formula.
But this, I think, is cleaner.
Great.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
YUFEI ZHAO: Ah, OK.
So why is this step true?
So if you expand
the right-hand side,
you see that the right-hand side
is upper bounded by all these
a, b, c, as in--
same as over here,
x to the b plus 2c.
And because how many terms--
and, also, there's a
binomial coefficient term.
So, basically, I'm doing
the multinomial expansion,
except I toss out everything
which is not part of the index.
And because b plus 2c
is, at most, 2n over 3,
I get M times x
to the 2n over 3.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
YUFEI ZHAO: Now I want to
convey a sense of mystique
about this proof.
This is a really cool proof.
So because you're
seeing a lecture,
maybe it went by very quickly.
But when this proof came out,
people were very shocked.
They didn't expect that this
problem would be tackled,
would be solved using a
method that is so unexpected.
And this is part of this
power of the algebraic method
in combinatorics,
where we often end up
with these short,
surprising proofs that
take a very long time to find.
But they turn out
to be very short.
So this is very short.
This was basically
a four-page paper.
But when they work,
they work beautifully.
They work like magic.
But it's hard to
predict when they work.
And, also, these methods
are somewhat fragile.
So, unlike the Fourier
analytic methods
that we saw last time, with
that method, it's very analytic.
It works in one situation,
you can play with it,
massage it, make it work
in a different situation.
Here, we're using something
very implicit, very special
about these many variables.
And if you try to tweak the
problem just a little bit,
the method seems to break down.
So, in particular,
it is open how
to extend this method
to other settings.
It's not even clear what
the results should be.
So it's open to extend
it to, for example, 4-AP.
So we do not know if the maximum
size of 4-AP-free subset of F5
to the n is less than some
constant, 4.99 to the n.
So that's very much open.
By the way, all of
this 3-AP stuff,
right now I've
only done it in F3,
but it works for 3-AP
in any finite field.
It also is open to
extend it to corners.
So you can define a
notion of corners.
So, previously, we saw
corners in integer grid.
If I replace integer
by some other group,
you can define a notion
of corners there.
So not clear how to extend
this method to corners.
And, also, is there some
way to extend some ideas
from this method
to the integers?
It completely fails, so this
method is not clear at all
how you might have
it work in a setting
where you don't have
this high dimensionality.
I mean, the result
will be different,
because, integers, we know
that there's no power saving,
but maybe you can get
some other bounds.
Any questions?
OK.
great.
Let's take a break.
So in the first part
of today's lecture,
I showed you a proof
of Roth's theorem.
In F3 to the n, that gave
you a much better bound
than what we did with Fourier.
Second part, I want to
show you another proof.
So yet another proof
of Roth in F2 to the n,
and this time giving
you a much worse bound.
But, of course, I do
this for a reason.
So it will give
you the new result.
So it will give you some more
information about 3-AP's and F3
to the n.
But the more important
reason is that in this course
I try to make some connections
between graph theory
on one hand and
additive combinatorics
on the other hand.
And, so far, we've
seen some analogies.
Well, in the proof of
Szemeredi's graph regularity
lemma versus the proof--
the Fourier analytic proof
of Roth's theorem, there was
this common theme of structure
versus pseudorandomness.
But the actual execution of the
proofs are somewhat different.
Because, on one hand,
in regularity lemma,
you have energy increment.
You have partitioning
and energy increment.
And, on the other
hand, with Roth,
you have density increment.
Or you're not partitioning.
You're zooming in.
Take a set, find some structure,
zoom in, find some structure,
zoom in.
You'll get density increment.
So it's similar, but
differently executed.
So, today-- I mean,
this second half,
I want to show you how to do
a different proof of Roth's
theorem that is much
more closely related
to the regularity proof, so
that has this energy increment
element to it.
And I show you this proof
because it also gives you
a stronger consequence.
And, namely, we'll
get that there is also
not just 3-AP's but 3-AP's
with popular difference.
So here's the result
that we'll see today.
So it's proved by Ben Green.
That for every epsilon, there
exists some n0 such that every
A in subset of F3 to the
n with density alpha,
there exists some nonzero y such
that the number of 3-AP's with
common difference y--
so let's think about
what's going on here.
So if I just give you
a set A and ask you
how many 3-AP's are
there, and compare it
to what you get from
random, random meaning
if A were a random set
of the same density.
So question is, can the
number of 3-AP's be less
than the random count?
And the answer is yes.
So, for example,
you could have--
in the integers, you can have
a barren type construction that
has no 3-AP's.
So, certainly, that's
fewer 3-AP's than random.
And you can do
similar things here.
But what Green's theorem
says is that there
exists some popular
common difference--
so this is a popular
such that the number
of 3-AP's in A
with this common difference
is at least as much as
what you should expect
in a random setting,
up to a minus epsilon.
So this is the theorem.
So let me say the
intuition again.
It says that, given
an arbitrary set A,
provided the space
dimension is large enough,
there exists some popular
common difference,
where popular means that
the number of 3-AP's
with that common difference
is at least roughly as many
as random.
In particular, this
proves Roth's theorem,
because you have at
least some 3-AP's.
But it tells you more.
It tells you there's some
common difference that
has a lot of 3-AP's,
even though, on average,
if you just take an average,
if you take a random y,
this is false.
Any questions about
the statement?
So Green developed
an arithmetic analog
of Szemeredi's graph
regularity lemma
in order to prove this theorem.
So starting with Szemeredi's
graph regularity lemma,
he found a way to import that
technique into the arithmetic
setting, in F3 to the n.
So I want to show you how,
roughly, how this is done.
And just like in Szemeredi's
graph regularity lemma,
there were unavoidable bounds
which are of power type,
the same thing is true in
the arithmetic setting.
So Green's proof shows
that the theorem is true,
with n0 being something
like tower in--
a tower of twos.
The height of the tower is a
polynomial in 1 over epsilon.
So just like in regularity
lemma for graphs.
So this was recently
improved in a paper
by Fox and Pham just a
couple of years ago, where--
and this is the proof that
I will show you today--
where you can take n0 to be
slightly better but still
a tower, but a tower of now
height log in 1 over epsilon.
So it's from a really,
really big tower
to slightly less big tower.
But, more importantly,
it turns out--
so they also showed
that this is tight.
You cannot do better.
There exists constructions,
there exist sets A for which
you--
I mean, this theorem
is false if you
replace the big O by less
than some very small constant.
So many applications of
the regularity lemma.
That first proof, maybe using
regularity, is difficult. Well,
it gives you a very poor bound.
But, subsequently, there were
other proofs, better proofs,
that give you
non-tower type bounds.
But this is the
first application
that we've seen
where, it turns out,
the regularity lemma gives
you the correct bound.
So it's really-- you
need a tower-type bound.
I mean, we know the
regularity lemma
itself needs tower-type bounds.
But it turns out
this application also
needs tower-type bounds.
That's quite interesting.
So, here, the use
of regularity is
really necessary in
this quantitative sense.
So let's see the proof.
So let me first prove a
slightly technical lemma
about bounded increments.
So this is-- corresponds
to the statement
that if you have
energy increments,
you can not increase
too many times,
but in a slightly
different form.
So suppose you have
numbers alpha and epsilon
bigger than 0.
And if you have this sequence
of a's between 0 and 1,
and such that a0
is at least alpha,
then there exists
some k, at most log
base 2 of 1 over
epsilon, such that 2
a sub k minus a sub k
plus 1 is at least alpha
cubed minus epsilon.
So don't worry about this form.
We'll see shorty why we
want something like that.
But the proof itself is
very straightforward.
Because, otherwise--
so you start with a0.
Now, then, if this is not
true for k equals to 0,
then a1 is at least 2 a0 minus
epsilon cubed plus epsilon.
So a0 is at least alpha cubed.
So if-- otherwise, you have
some lower bound on alpha
1, which is at least
alpha cubed plus epsilon.
And, likewise, you have
some lower bound on alpha 2.
You have some lower bound on--
sorry-- alpha 2, and this
lower bound is plus 2 epsilon.
So you keep iterating.
You see the next thing
is 4 epsilon, and so on.
So if you get to more
than this many iterations,
you go more than 1.
So alpha k is bigger than 1
if k is ceiling of log base 2
of 1 over epsilon.
And that will be a
contradiction to the hypothesis.
So this is a small variation
on this fact that you cannot
increment too many times.
Each time, you go up by a bit.
Whereas, we save a little
bit because the number
of iterations is
now logarithmic.
So you double in
epsilon each time.
If I give you a function f on F3
to the n, and U is a subspace--
so this notation means subspace.
Let me write f sub U to
be the function obtained
by averaging f on each U coset.
So you have some subspace.
You partition your space into
translates of that subspace,
and you replace the
value of f on each coset
by its average on that coset.
So this is similar to
what we did with graphons.
You're stepping.
So you're averaging
on each block.
So now let me prove
something which
is kind of like an
arithmetic regularity lemma.
And I mean, this statement
will be new to you,
but it should look similar to
some of the statements we've
seen before in the course.
And the statement is
that, for every epsilon,
there exists some m which
is a function of epsilon.
And, in fact, it
will be bounded,
in terms of tower of
height, at most order
logarithmic in 1 over epsilon.
Such that for every
function f on F3
to the n that are values bounded
between 0 and 1, there exists
subspaces W and U, where
the codimension of W
is, at most, m.
So you should think of this
as the course partition
and the fine partition in the
partition regularity lemma.
And the codimension is--
corresponds to the
number of pieces.
So three ways to codimension
is the number of cosets.
So you have bounded many
parts, and have two partitions.
And what I would like
is that the number--
so if I--
I want f to be pseudorandom
after doing this partitioning,
so to speak.
And this corresponds
to the statement
that if I look f minus fW, then
the maximum Fourier coefficient
is quite small, where
quite small means, at most,
epsilon over the
size of U complement.
So size of U perp.
And, also, there is
this other condition
which tells you that the
L3 norms between f sub U
and f sub W are
related in this way.
So we haven't seen this before.
In fact, specifically, this
inequality is very ad hoc
to the application of
popular difference in 3-AP's.
But we have seen
something similar,
where this relationship
is replaced
by something that accounts
for the difference between L2
norms.
So if you go back
to your notes, when
we discussed regularity lemma
in a more analytic fashion,
we have that.
And you should
think of this-- when
we discussed strong regularity
lemma, this definition here,
this roughly corresponds
to definition
that in the fine partition
versus the course partition
the edge densities are
roughly similar, that when you
do the further partitioning,
you're not changing densities
up by very much.
So that's the arithmetic
regularity lemma.
And once you have
the statement--
I mean, I think the hardest part
is writing down the statement.
Once you have the statement,
the proof itself is kind of this
follow your nose approach,
where you first define
the sequence of epsilons.
Epsilon 0 is 1, and
epsilon sub k plus 1--
and don't worry
about this for now.
You will see in a second why
these numbers are chosen.
Let me write R sub k to be the
set of r's-- so there will be
characters--
such that the Fourier
coefficient fr
is at least epsilon sub k.
So the r's are supposed
to identify how we're
going to do the partitioning.
Now, the size of
this R is bounded.
So I claim that the
size of R is, at most, 1
over epsilon sub k squared.
And that's because there is
this parsable identity, which
tells you that the L2 sum
of the Fourier coefficients
is equal to the L2 of the
function, which is at most 1.
So the number of Fourier
coefficients that exceed
a certain quantity
cannot be too many.
So let U now be the
subspace defined by taking
the orthogonal
complement of these r's.
And let's note that if we
take alpha sub k to be the--
if we take alpha sub k to be the
L3 norm cubed of the function
derived from averaging f along
the U's, and then looking
at the third moment
of these densities.
So these alphas, we can apply
the increment lemma initially
to deduce that there exists--
so, in particular, this
number here is at least alpha
cubed by convexity.
So by the previous lemma, there
exists some k, no more than
on the order of 1 over--
of log 1 over epsilon,
such that 2 alpha sub
k minus alpha sub k plus
1 is at least the density
of f cubed minus epsilon.
So this alpha is supposed
to be the density of f.
So we find this k.
And we have this bound
over here from satisfying
that inequality.
So this is the density increment
argument, the energy increment
argument.
So we're doing the energy
increment argument, basically
the same argument
as the one that we
did when we discussed
graph regularity lemma,
but now presented in a
slightly different form
and a different order of logic.
But it's the same argument.
And what we would like
to show is that you also
have this pseudorandomness
condition about having
small Fourier coefficients.
So what's happening here with
the Fourier coefficients?
Now, how is the Fourier
coefficient of an average
f related to the original f?
So that's something you
want to understand up there.
And that's something
that's not hard to analyze.
Because if you have
a function U or W--
so either one-- then
the Fourier coefficients
of this average version
is very much related
to the original function.
It turns out that if
you take an r which
is in the orthogonal complement,
then the Fourier coefficient
doesn't change.
And if you are not in the
orthogonal complement,
then the Fourier
coefficient gets zeroed out.
So that's something that's
not too hard to check,
and I urge you to
think about it.
So, with that in mind, let's go
back to verify this over here.
So what we have
now is that the--
so this quantity, which
measures the largest Fourier
coefficient, the difference
between f and U sub k plus 1,
is, at most--
and what U sub k
plus 1 is doing is
we're looking at possible
large Fourier coefficients,
and we are getting rid of them.
So we're zeroing out these
large Fourier coefficients,
so that the remaining
Fourier coefficients are all
quite small.
But we chose our R so that if--
so this big R--
so that if your little
r is not in big R,
then the Fourier
coefficient must be small.
That's how we chose
the big R. So we
have this bound over here.
And by the definition of the
epsilon, we have that bound.
And, also, we're combining
with this estimate,
upper bound estimate
on the size of R sub k.
So point being we have that.
So now take W to be U sub k
plus 1, and U to b U sub k,
and then we have
everything that we want.
Question, yes.
AUDIENCE: Why is the
codimension of W small?
YUFEI ZHAO: Question is, why
is the codimension of W small?
So what is the codimension of W?
So we want to know that the
codimension of W is bounded.
So the codimension of W is--
I mean, the codimension of
any of these U sub k's is,
at most, 3 raised to the
number of r's that produce it.
And the size of R is bounded.
So if we pick m so that it
uniformly bounds the size of R,
then we have a bound
on the codimension.
So that's important.
So we need to know that
the codimension is small.
Otherwise, if you don't have
the bound on codimension
you can just take
the zero subspace,
and, trivially,
everything's true.
We have a regularity lemma, and
what comes with a regularity
lemma is a counting lemma.
So let me write down
the counting lemma,
and I'll skip the proof.
So the counting lemma tells
you that if you have f and g
both functions on F3 to the n,
and U is a subspace F, then--
so let me define--
so the quantity that
I'm interested in is--
so I'm interested in
understanding 3-AP's where
the common difference is
in a particular subspace.
So we claim that the 3-AP count
of f with common difference
restricted to the subspace U--
so it's similar between
f and g if f and g are
close to each other in Fourier.
Well, not quite, because--
so something like
this, we saw earlier
in the proof of Roth's
theorem if we don't
restrict the common difference.
Turns out, if you restrict
the common difference,
you lose a little bit.
So you lose a factor
which is basically
the size of the complement
of U. So I won't prove that.
But now let me go on
to the punch line.
So if we start with, again,
f function in your space,
taking bounds between 0 and 1,
and I have subspaces U and W,
I claim that the--
if I look at f
averaged through W,
and I consider 3-AP counts with
common difference restricted
to U, then this
quantity here is lower
bounded by this difference
between L3 norms.
So I claim this is true.
So this is just some inequality.
This is some inequality.
So of all the things that
I did back in high school
doing math competitions, I
think the one skill which,
I think, I find
most helpful now is
being able to do inequalities.
And I thought I would never
see these three-variable
inequalities again, but
when I saw this one--
so Fox and Pham, when
they first showed me
a somewhat different
proof of an approach that
didn't go through this specific
inequality, I told them,
hey, there's this thing I
remember from high school.
It's called Schur's inequality.
And I thought I would never
see it again after high school,
but apparently
it's still useful.
So what Schur's
inequality says--
this is one of those
three-variable inequalities
that you would know if
you did math olympiads--
that you have-- so
it's an inequality
between non-negative-- actually,
it's true for real numbers
as well, but let's say it's
non-negative real numbers.
So that's Schur's equality.
So if you look at the left-hand
side, the left-hand side is--
it can be written as a
sum in the following way.
I mean, it can be written
in the following way.
So its expectation over
x, y, z that are 3-AP's
in the same U coset.
So I'm counting 3-AP's with
common difference restricted
to U. So common 3-AP's
in the same U coset.
And I am looking at
the product of f sub
W evaluated on this 3-AP.
So what I would like to do now
is apply Schur's inequality
to a, b, and c, being
these three numbers.
The point is you have
this a, b, c on the left.
And then everything on the
right involves only a subset
of a, b, c, and they simplify.
So if I do this, then I
lower bound this quantity
by twice the expectation of
x and y in the same coset,
same U coset of f sub W
of x squared f sub W of y.
Maybe I took two other
things, but they're
all symmetric with
respect to each other.
And minus the term
that corresponds
to this sum of cubes.
So like that.
So this is a consequence
of Schur's equality applied
with a, b, c like this.
But now you see, over here,
I can analyze this expression
even further.
Because if I let y vary
within the same U coset,
then, over here, it
averages out to U cosets.
So U is bigger than W.
So what we have is--
so what we have over here
is that it is at least twice
of f of f--
f of U-- fW squared fU minus
the expectation of fW squared--
fW cubed.
And I can use
convexity on f sub W
to get that, which is
what we're looking for.
So the last step is convexity.
So I'm running
through a little bit
quick here because we're
running out of time,
but all of these
steps are fairly
simple once you observe
the first thing you can do
is Schur's inequality.
And we're almost there.
We're almost done.
So from that lemma
up there, I claim now
that, for every
epsilon, there exists
some m which is tower log
in 1 over epsilon, such
that if f is a function
on F3 to the n,
taking bounds
between 0 and 1, then
there exists a subspace
U of codimension,
at most, m such that
the 3-AP count, 3-AP
density with common
difference restricted to U,
is at least the random
bound minus epsilon.
Why is this true?
Well, we put everything
together, and choose U and W
as in regularity lemma.
And, by counting lemma, we have
that the 3-AP density of f,
so it is at least--
so we're using counting
lemma over here--
it is at least the 3-AP
density of f sub W of U
minus a small error
which we can control.
So this step is counting.
And now we apply that
inequality up there.
And finally, we chose our U
and W in the regularity lemma
so that this difference
here is controlled.
So it is controlled by the
random bound minus epsilon.
And that's it.
So you change
epsilon to 4 epsilon,
but we can change it back.
And that's it.
So we have the
statement that you
have this subspace of
bounded codimension where
you have this popular
difference result.
It doesn't quite guarantee you
a single common difference,
because, well, you
don't really want
it to be the case where U is
just a single point because I
want a nonzero
common difference.
But if U is large enough--
if n is large enough
at bounded codimension,
so, then, the size
of U is large enough.
So, then, there exists some
nonzero common difference.
You pick some nonzero
element of U. On average,
this should work out just fine.
So I'll leave that
detail to you.
One more thing I
want to mention is
that all of this machinery
involving regularity
and Fourier, as with
things we've done before,
carries over to other settings--
general Abelian groups,
and also the integers.
And you may ask, well,
we have this for 3-AP's.
What about longer
arithmetic progressions?
In the integers, it
turns out it is also
true, that Green's
statement, in the integers
if you replace 3-AP by 4-AP.
That's a theorem
of Green and Tao
involving higher-order quadratic
analysis-- quadratic Fourier
analysis.
However, and rather
surprisingly, 4-AP, it's OK.
But 5-AP and
longer, it is false.
The corresponding statement
about popular differences
for 5-AP in the
integers is false.
There are counterexamples.
So it's really a statement about
3-AP's and 4-AP's, and there's
some magic cancellations
that happen
in 4-AP's that make it true.
OK, great.
So that's all for today.